our next presenter is a great romantic
movie star in spite of the fact that in
his most recent love story he painted
his face blue and had shoulder length
hair and wore a skirt I think I was
married to him
ladies and gentlemen Oscar nominee Mel
Gibson
I know this category is best foreign
language film but it seems like foreign
is getting more familiar every day the
stories these films tell the different
mirrors they hold to nature the various
cultures they celebrate reminders were
all part of one global village from
Algeria Yugoslavia 41 countries
submitted films to the Academy these
five were nominated as Best Foreign
Language Film from Sweden all things
bear Boveda Berg director from the
Netherlands Antonia's line Marlene Goris
director from Algeria dust of life
Richard Rashid Boosh Arab director
that's pretty good and from Brazil Oh
qua trio fabio burrito yeah it's kind of
funny director and from Italy the star
makers Giuseppe Tornatore directly you
starting to enjoy this and the Oscar is
presented to the Netherlands for
Antonia's line
some people have called Antonia's line
of fairytale perhaps it is and that it
should win an Oscar is a fairy tale come
true for all of us involved in its
making I should like to thank the
members of the Academy for this
tremendous honor I'd also like to thank
my producer hamster ways for his
patience and perseverance my script
editor and translator Anthony Davis for
his lifelong friendship my first
assistant and friend Maria at a hack for
her invaluable help and support and of
course my mother without whom I wouldn't
have all this fun my thanks also to my
Belgium and English co-produces Nina
Lombardo
and Judy Counahan and I can't begin to
express my gratitude to the marvelous
cast of antonius line in particular
Villach of animal Roy for her fine
Antonia and of course many many many
thanks to the dutch belgiam and english
crew members and specifically to die
direct right director photography
village dawson lastly i want to express
my thanks to the American distributor of
antonius line first look pictures Ellen
little decided last year at con that
this obscure Dutch film was a film that
people in the States really should see
and here is ease thank you all very much
now I'm very pleased to introduce an
Academy award-winning director and a
winner of the Irving G Thalberg award a
very courageous man who gave me my first
job in the movies
ladies and gentlemen Steven Spielberg